esta es una de las más de 1000 escuelas
que han sido dañadas desde el comienzo
de este conflicto este es un edificio de
tres plantas no queda nada en pie como
pueden ver el panorama es desolador las
paredes están completamente estropeadas
hay restos del techo que están a punto
de caerse bancos que han quedado
completamente calcinado también cables
sueltos restos de libros hardcore la
ciudad en la que nos encontramos sigue
siendo una de las localidades más
afectadas de este conflicto de hecho en
las últimas horas las autoridades
ucranianas han informado que las tropas
rusas han lanzado una nueva ofensiva
sobre esta ciudad que recordemos es la
segunda localidad más importante de
ucrania y ya había sido asediada al
comienzo de este conflicto esto también
refleja que la guerra en ucrania está
lejos de apagarse lo ha dicho también
hoy el secretario general de la otan
quien ha afirmado que este conflicto
podría durar